-Well, here's what
people are talking about.
A huge, huge political story.
Last night, Doug Jones
pulled off a shocking win
over Roy Moore to become
Senator of Alabama.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you know it's been a crazy
year when an alleged pedophile
loses a Senate race,
and we're like,
"Wow. What an upset!
I thought the pedophile
was gonna win!"
What?
Yep, Roy Moore became
the first Republican
to lose an Alabama Senate race
in 25 years.
It was so embarrassing,
his horse went home in an Uber.
"You Sassy the horse? Get in.
What kind of music you like?"
As the results came in,
reporters said it was very quiet
at Moore's campaign
headquarters.
But to be fair,
it was a school night, so...
-Hey-oh! Ho. Ho. Ho!
-But you could tell things
weren't going well.
One of Moore's spokesmen went
on CNN to defend his belief
that Muslims
can't run for office.
And he got some
surprising information.
Watch his reaction.
-You don't actually have to
swear on a Christian Bible.
You can swear on
anything, really.
I don't know if you knew that.
You can swear on a Jewish Bible.
-Oh, no. I swore on the Bible.
I've done it three times.
-I'm sure you have.
I'm sure you've picked a Bible.
But the law is not that you have
to swear on a Christian Bible.
That is not the law.
You don't know that?
All right. Ted Crockett...
[ Laughter ]
-Blink twice for yes, Ted.
He looks like he just found out
he's been saying his wife's name
wrong for 20 years.
She's like,
"It's Less-lee, not Lez-lee."
But a lot of Republicans
are blaming Steve Bannon
for the loss.
Today, Congressman Peter King
went on CNN
and made some pretty interesting
remarks about him.
Listen to this.
-This guy does not belong
on the national stage.
He looks like
some disheveled drunk
that wandered onto
the political stage.
-Did you just call Steve Bannon
a disheveled drunk?
-No, to be very precise,
I said he looks like one.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-"I'm not saying he's ugly.
I'm just saying he looks ugly.
That's all I'm saying.
I would never --
I would never say that."
And one of the big reasons
for Doug Jones' victory
was because 98%
of African-American women
supported him.
Joining me now to talk about it
is "Tonight Show" correspondent
Yamaneika Saunders, everybody.
Yamaneika. Oh, no.
Oh, no. Oh, no!
Oh, no! What happened?!
-Oh! Oh!
-Oh, what happened?
-My back is hurting.
-Oh, no. Your back hurts?
-Yeah, every black woman's
back is hurting
from carrying the election
last night!
-Oh. Very good. [ Laughs ]
So you're excited about
the results in Alabama?
-Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, a Democrat won
in Alabama?
That's like Kanye West saying,
"No, not anymore about me.
More about you."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you're feeling pretty good?
-Oh, yeah, I feel like Superman,
you know, because
we both save the world
and we both wear Spanx.
-Absolutely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Mm-hmm. Now, listen.
This is the perfect example
of black-girl magic, okay?
After the 2016 election,
we were like,
"You know what? Sit down.
We got this."
-Really?
-Yeah!
Black women get it done.
I mean, y'all seen
"Hidden Figures."
Okay? We sent
y'all asses to space.
-All right. That's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good point.
You guys showed up.
You showed up.
-Yeah, absolutely.
We showed up like we thought
Barack, Idris, and Denzel
were gonna be there.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
-I mean, Jimmy, this was our
iPhone release line, you know?
Except, you know,
we were waiting in line
for a guy named Doug.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
iPhone release line.
So do you think black women are
celebrating in Alabama today?
-Oh, yeah. Well, we're
super-excited, you know?
We're excited
like Roy Moore would be
if they let him
back into Limited Too.
-Oh, yeah. That's exciting.
Yeah, yeah.
Before I let you go, what do you
think Roy Moore should do next?
-Oh, what do I think?
-Yeah.
-What do I think?
I think he need
to get back on that horse
and saddle his ass
up to "Westworld."
-All right, very good.
Yamaneika Saunders, everybody.
-Michelle 2020! Michelle 2020!
-Yamaneika Saunders.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Listen to this, you guys.
Paul Ryan revealed that he
hasn't eaten sweets in 10 years.
He said he'd rather eat grilled
asparagus than a Snickers.
Americans were like,
"And we thought Roy Moore
was a monster.
I mean, this guy is insane!
What are you talking about?!"
"Happy Halloween.
Here's a grilled asparagus.
It's a fun-size
grilled asparagus."
Did you guys hear about this?
Apparently George Clooney
once gave his 14 best friends
$1 million each.
They were thrilled, while
his 15th-best friend was like,
"What the hell, man?
Like, are we cool?
Were you having a barbecue
or something? Come on, man.
Remember when we had that thing
that one time?
We're kind of buddies, right?
Come on."
Finally, this is very cute.
The other day in Indiana,
a little boy and little girl
were in the middle
of a school wrestling match,
and the girl's younger brother
didn't seem to like what he saw.
Check this out.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Yeah! There he --
Oh, there he goes.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm told that kid
just signed with the WWE.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!